tengo miedo
vamos a levantarnos por favor levántense
todos en sus asientos vamos a
despabilarnos como dice mi mamá
despabílate
y ahora vamos a hacer esta parte
y no no es una clase de aerobics de
nuestra querida maestra karen
muy bien siéntense ya no se estiren de
más porque alguien se puede estirar
mucho más y sacarnos a todos
las ciudades están enfermas
no se olviden de esa parte
ahora imaginemos e imagina
esa ciudad en la que has nacido
en la que has crecido
esa ciudad que has visitado
esa ciudad incluso
que ha sufrido
y esta historia que vamos a contar no es
mía sino es de todos porque todos la
hemos vivido
cuando salimos a la calle
imagina también esa ciudad en la que has
jugado en esa ciudad en la que juegan
tus hijos quién sale en la foto
es mi hija
y va a salir en otro momento también
ahora imagínate ese esquema del cuerpo
humano que conocemos desde hace mucho
tiempo que conocemos desde la primaria
cuando nos mandaban por las láminas a la
papelería un lunes el sistema
circulatorio y el miércoles y el sistema
respiratorio ya hoy por el internet casi
no se ocupa pero aún existen las láminas
y lo digo porque mamá tiene una
papelería y me toca a veces organizarlas
ahora vamos a imaginar
la ciudad
y el cuerpo humano en una sola imagen
no es difícil hacerlo porque las
ciudades como el cuerpo humano
está compuesta de muchos sistemas
sistemas dentro de otro sistema de sus
sistemas y nos representa imágenes así
la ciudad se enferma porque es un
sistema complejo
es un sistema de sistemas sumamente
amplio y complicado pero que aún así
funciona
estas ciudades de hoy se enfrentan a
retos increíblemente intensos
se enfrentan a situaciones únicas a
situaciones específicas las situaciones
que en este mundo global en donde los
latidos de la ciudad y de nosotros van
cada vez más rápido requiere encontrar
soluciones
requiere encontrar alternativas
hoy estamos en este lugar en esta charla
pero esta charla te va a llegar a todo
el mundo estas ciudades globales están
súper conectadas la globalidad nos
promueve a que disminuyamos los tiempos
y las distancias en megabytes
en gigabytes en información y así como
hoy nos están viendo aquí nos ven en
otros lados del mundo o del universo
danos está pendiente de nosotros y
tienes esa cara de susto porque dice que
está hablando gabriel en este momento
ahora
la globalidad y el capitalismo porque
hay que decirlo así ha generado riesgo
sumamente fuertes ha generado
situaciones que todo el mundo de los que
estamos hoy aquí que nos están viendo
han sufrido y que ha implicado un
sacrificio y voy a hablar en específico
de méxico y ese proceso de crecimiento
que ha tenido nuestro país para llegar a
la situación en la que nos encontramos
hoy
de una mega urbanización les voy a
presentar a alguien que tal vez ustedes
conocen y que si no conocen se van a
tener que llevar de tarea para ver sus
dos películas
él es tránsito
mejor conocido como el mil usos
esta persona y este actor y este
personaje represento a esa generación de
los años setentas ochentas que escapaba
de la pobreza del campo para ir y como
dice el cartel tratar de conquistar la
ciudad
e insisto mucho en que tienes que verlo
porque él representa a muchas de las
personas que hoy habitan y que
construyeron las ciudades en las que
habitamos
en ese momento escapaban de la crisis
del campo y que buscaban un sueño de
poder realizar en las ciudades de hoy
en mi caso soy primera generación aquí
en toluca mis padres me migran en estos
tiempos desde hidalgo y desde michoacán
se conocen aquí y por algo nacimos
nosotros
algo pasó no no quiero ni imaginar qué
pasó
pero aquí estamos
fíjate lo grave y lo interesante de este
mundo
de 1940 1980
tuvimos la etapa de crecimiento más
intenso en el país pasamos de 19.7
millones a más de 66 millones haciendo
de la ciudad de mexico y de la zona
conurbada del valle de mexico pasar de
1.5 a 14.5 millones de personas
habitando ese lugar
y la situación no crean que en estos
tiempos se va a componer o va a ser
mejor
para el año 2030 nosotros vamos a pasar
de 384 ciudades a 961 ciudades es decir
que más del 80 por ciento de los
mexicanos vamos a decidir vivir en
ciudades que ya existen pero lo más
interesante es que vamos a pasar a vivir
a ciudades nuevas y los riesgos se van a
incrementar y la situación no es solo
negativo no es que exista migración sino
que no estamos preparados para recibir y
tratar de controlar el tema por eso yo
les invito a que me acompañen
acompañando un ratito a ver esta
situación las ciudades repito son como
el cuerpo humano y se enferman
estas enfermedades cuáles son
ahorita vamos a ver solamente algunos
casos pero las dividimos en físicas
biológicas y sociales porque esto se
tiene que tratar de manera compleja lo
simple lo reduccionista nos limita hoy
vamos a ver algunos ejemplos y lo
primero que tenemos que hacer es
identificar los síntomas es como cuando
vamos al doctor realizar un diagnóstico
que nos permita encontrar la solución
pero sobre todo requerimos aceptar es
como cuando tenemos una enfermedad no
grave o grave y no vamos al doctor
porque pensamos que se va a solucionar
con el tiempo o cuando es más grave y lo
escuchamos en una charla anterior
tenemos miedo
de aceptarlo y si no lo aceptamos no lo
podemos curar
esta analogía tiene que ver con algo que
todo mundo conocemos
que todo mundo padecemos y que hemos
visto en carne propia enfermedades que
se han llevado a nuestros familiares por
este motivo es el asunto del colesterol
el colesterol urbano todo mundo
identifica esta imagen verdad las venas
arterias y lo amarillo es el colesterol
es la grasa que se ha ido acumulando
derivado de nuestras malas decisiones a
través del tiempo y de la ausencia de
acciones que nos permitan evitarlo
lo mismo pasa con nosotros cuantos de
los que estamos aquí llegaron caminando
levanten la mano
cuantos llegaron en auto particular
en camión
los menos somos más los que llegamos en
coche particular y este es nuestro
colesterol
el colesterol de la ciudad lo que está
ahogando y generando problemas en toda
la ciudad
esta es mi calle hace 28 años mi perra a
ti ya mi hermano está está ahí atrás y
es casi en el centro de la ciudad de
toluca después de las seis de la tarde
salíamos a echar los chutes sin problema
o un sábado domingo estaba prácticamente
vacío hoy está así
ni imaginar que mi hija salga a jugar
después de las 6
la situación se vuelve cada vez más
compleja y esta infografía la asayish
méndez una arquitecta colimense derivado
de un análisis que se hizo en todo el
país y nos dice algo interesante más del
70 por ciento de la gente en mexico se
mueve al trabajo en bus caminando o en
bicicleta más del 70% pero solamente el
28 por ciento se mueve en auto
particular se dan cuenta de eso el
mínimo de la población es quien tiene
congestionada a las ciudades y eso no es
culpa de los que queremos tener coches y
no es un tema sistémico en donde no
tenemos las condiciones óptimas para
andar en bici para andar en camión o
para incluso tener banquetas dignas que
nos permitan caminar con comodidad están
de acuerdo
y existe una plataforma que cuando vi
esto es que estamos mal en realidad
tomtom es como ways es una aplicación de
navegación que hizo este análisis y
miren méxico es el país más
congestionado en la capital de méxico es
la ciudad más congestionada no solamente
de américa sino del mundo
ahora recuerdan esa imagen del
colesterol
a poco no se parece a esta situación
sumamente grave y lo grave no es eso
sino lo grave es que está generando otro
tipo de enfermedades en la ciudad tanto
físicas como biológicas quiénes somos
nosotros en este papel quiénes somos
nosotros en este juego de la ciudad
cuerpo humano somos los glóbulos rojos
somos la sangre somos aquello que lleva
los nutrientes
todos los sistemas que le permiten
funcionar
anemia urbana la anemia es la ausencia
de hierro y el de hierro es lo que
genera la hemoglobina y cuando existe
eso es una enfermedad que evita que el
oxígeno llegue a todas partes
y cual creen que sean los nutrientes o
cuál es el nutriente esencial en una
ciudad
el espacio público
lo verde el parque el jardín esos
lugares donde se supone que vamos a
divertirnos y hacer felices esos lugares
que nos deben otorgar tranquilidad esos
lugares que buscamos como escape ante la
situación diaria que vivimos esos
lugares donde los niños deben de ser
felices porque el espacio público según
jordi borja y estoy seguro que no sólo
él sino tú tú y tú significa felicidad
significa calidad de vida significa
vivir más
el espacio público es eso son los
espacios y los lugares que nos hacen
felices y está comprobado que la gente
feliz vive más está comprobado que
pensar y ser como niños aunque seamos
adultos y salir y jugar en los juegos
nos hace más felices y aquí entra una
comprobación de esa enfermedad que hoy
vivimos la organización mundial de la
salud recomienda que cada uno de
nosotros debemos de tener 10 metros
cuadrados de áreas verdes eso significa
que este círculo lo multiplicamos por 5
y cada uno de nosotros deberíamos de
tener esa dimensión para ser felices y
tener una mejor salud y en todo lo que
tenemos 1.7 millones de metros cuadrados
de áreas verdes contando los k millones
de toyo kan y el sierra morelos
esos saben que nos genera
esto
dos metros cuadrados por habitante en
toluca solamente tenemos eso y eso
enferma a cualquiera y hace destacar
intenten hacerlo
si me sale
ahora las ciudades que vivimos en este
mundo capitalista son ciudades un poco
más injustas sociedades que están
anémicas y que vivimos en la injusticia
eso es una realidad como conectamos lo
físico y lo biológico las ciudades de
hoy no se enferman
qué tal quien se sienta en los nubes hoy
ingrid al honor
estas son las enfermedades de hoy los
domingos en la noche antes de ir a
trabajar son los comerciales que saturan
la televisión y satura todo es el ritmo
de vida que vivimos y este ritmo de vida
es comprobable en una de las
enfermedades características de la
sociedad mexicana que tiene que ver con
esos procesos de urbanización y sus
procesos que hoy vivimos si es la
diabetes vean ustedes en 1980 cuánta
gente moría por diabetes y ahora vean el
2016 dejamos de movernos
dejamos de cuidarnos dejamos de pasar y
vivir en el campo para vivir en la
ciudad se dan cuenta de esa relación que
existe ahora también quien ha pensado en
que los parques y la ausencia de parques
está relacionada con la obesidad
infantil sin quitar la responsabilidad
de los papás
no hay parques no hay actividad hay
ociosidad estas imágenes son de asia y
pensábamos hace algún tiempo que eran
normales sin embargo no es así hoy esta
es la ciudad de toluca
una de las ciudades o la ciudad más
contaminada del país y que nos puso hace
unas semanas a nivel mundial a competir
con otras ciudades
esta es mi hija pintando me las uñas
tiene 4 años
pero saben que es lo más complicado
que ella y todos los niños de esa edad
en toluca no han respirado un solo día
de aire limpio como lo hicimos nosotros
hace muchos años porque la calidad de
aire ha sido pésima desde hace cinco
años no saben qué es eso y pudiese
parecer normal pero no lo es por eso
requerimos accionar nos nosotros
requerimos estar tristes pero sobre todo
saber que nuestras ciudades agonizan
pero que hay esperanza
existe la esperanza existe esa situación
que tenemos y que requerimos pensar como
salvamos las ciudades como salvas tú a
esas niñas y niños del futuro hoy mi
hija y tus hijos
no van a tener aire limpio
pero como corregimos eso cómo nos
organizamos para salvar a nuestro
planeta
a nuestro ciudad nuestra ciudad una vez
es hablarle a los
cómo se llama
superhéroes pero aquí se va a hacer
realidad el sueño de andrés
ser superhéroe o le hablas a los
avengers o le hablas a los guardianes
del conocimiento y a los generadores del
conocimiento que todos los que están ahí
estuvimos aquí en este círculo
platicando te y compartiendo te y que tú
puedes ser un superhéroe y tú lo puedes
ser cuando tú quieras pero que la base
de eso es la miel del conocimiento la
generación del conocimiento es el único
legado que nosotros vamos a poder
dejarles más allá de propiedades más
allá de satisfacciones personales que
esas se morirán cuando yo me muera pero
a mi hija ya tus hijos ya los niños que
no son míos pero que aún no nacen les
quiero dejar conocimiento para que no
vivan en ciudades como las que nosotros
vivimos hoy para corregir esa parte y
tratar los temas desde el enfoque
multidisciplinario interdisciplinario
transversal y sobre todo
universal universitario pensar en
colectivo requerimos pensar en los demás
pensar en cómo hacer todo para los demás
dejar de usar el auto por favor eso es
muy importante hacer ciudad y hacer
comunidad como lo hicimos cuando salimos
a pintar cebras peatonales para
disminuir la mortalidad infantil saben
los niños mexicanos de que se mueren la
primera causa de atropellamiento no se
mueren de diarrea o de pulmonía nosotros
salimos a diseñar las ciudades a escala
humana y le regresamos un poquito de
color a esa ciudad que hoy no es de los
humanos es del auto requerimos corregir
eso requerimos hacerlo y diseñar
participativamente qué implica eso y
este mensaje es para universitarios
docentes alumnos gobierno de los tres
niveles la ciudad se diseña entre todos
la ciudad se hace entre todos
para que exista esto
pensar en el otro fundamental ver el
espacio público como la política número
uno pública para hacer ciudad y cuidar
la salud de la ciudad y cuidar la salud
de cada uno de nosotros requerimos
luchar por nuestra ciudad requerimos
luchar por cada metro cuadrado de áreas
verdes porque cada metro de áreas verdes
significará la salud de las futuras
generaciones requerimos rescatar los
parques públicos que existan y promover
que existan cada vez más porque ya
sabemos que el espacio público genera
felicidad a ti que tienes 10 a ti que
tienes 20 a ti que tiene 50 años no
importa es lo que requerimos hacer es lo
que requerimos promover accionar nos
para que para nosotros ser responsables
universitarios
para nosotros ser responsables con
nuestras ciudades para nosotros lograr
eso que hoy ha sido sumamente complejo
aquí con mis alumnos lo que hice e
hicimos fue salir y entregarle al
ayuntamiento de toluca 18 propuestas de
parques de barrio se los otorgamos como
universitarios en esa hicimos lo mismo
la miel del conocimiento no se regatea
la miel del conocimiento se ofrece y esa
es la responsabilidad de la
universalidad de las ideas y del ser
universitario nuestro mayor legado es
eso la generación del conocimiento para
vivir nosotros en lugares de respuestas
y soluciones y vivir en un lugar mejor
muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]